hold on everyone  I think I'd probably use the  chronosphere to go back to like a day  that was either really fun and relaxing  or just like when I was like I don't  know toddler or something so that I  didn't have to be responsible or  anything someone would just like put me  in a pram and take me to sleep or  something I think when the listeners of  the film is don't change the past isn't  it um I don't know it's I I think I love  the idea of time travel but I'd go there  purely as an observer I think I would  like to swiftness things you know things  of great historic consequence or just go  I'd like to go back into the past and  visit a restaurant oil at the tavern in  like the 17th century and just listen  and you know that would be fascinating  to me  but I not sure I would have change  anything it's too risky dangerous nd  there I would go back in time and I  would ride on a dinosaur as they look so  much fun i defied the t-rex your time  yourself  you